so you know 20 when you have the
audacity to have a show where you're
answering other people's questions it's
very easy to have that whole like not
looking at the Emperor's clothes or he's
naked or whatever the hell that is but
the truth is I really need to focus on
giving myself one huge piece of advice
which is right now in my career right
this second the amount of balls that I'm
dropping or more importantly to me the
amount of balls that I'm not grabbing
that I should be grabbing at in you of
me wanting to bring value to my audience
answering every email that I can
grabbing 15 minutes with every
up-and-coming entrepreneur what's
happening is I need to recognize I'm not
in a window like I was in between Wine
Library and vaynermedia or even where I
opened up a little bit of an opening in
the last year or two as vaynermedia has
gotten bigger my opportunities have
gotten bigger I'm heading into my 40th
birthday this is a very important next
decade for me and the truth is I need
some good old advice for myself so Gary
yes Gary you need to start focusing and
start saying no more often obviously
I've made a video in the past called the
yes virus I need to heed to that right
now I'm making this video mainly because
I want to send it to you somebody who
cared enough to email me and is looking
for advice or looking for 15 minutes or
looking for some spec opportunity and I
get thousands of those a day and they
crush me and I answer hundreds of them a
week and I take on 15 of them 25 of them
a month and 25 times 15 to 30 minutes is
something that is just really not smart
for me right now and I need to swallow
my pride or my my romance around being
the people's entrepreneur and being
around or the serendipity leads to
upside true buddy media if you know me
you know what I mean however plenty of
it tons of mass does not and I need
right now to take all those minutes back
mainly because one if you know me I
focused on my health I had to find that
hour I really need to find another hour
to go home and spend an hour each day
with my kids
whether I'm putting them to sleep or
giving them a bath and that's just
another hour I need back and that's
going to come out of this and very on
see I need to give another hour to the
500 people at vaynermedia in the hundred
people of wine library these are my
businesses like I have to give them time
I'm not doing as much mentorship for
them sometimes I feel like I'm engaging
with my audience more than I am with my
employees that feels wrong at least it
does right now and so I need to get my
[ __ ] together so I apologize I'm letting
you down but the truth is I need to heed
to this advice I'm giving myself that
not only am i dropping some balls which
is the scariest cuz if I'm entering the
game I want to deliver I'm just missing
bigger balls that I should be grabbing
out I know it's funny but it's the truth
and so that's what I need to do